thanks Ted will helping those who need
help in Moapa Valley neighborhood roads
that turned into rivers after severe
flooding about eight weeks ago well
people who live in that area which is
about 60 miles Northeast of Las Vegas
say they have asked for help but haven't
had any luck eight news now reporter
Ryan Matthey went there today to take
their concerns to those in charge
76 year old Oscar anchondo says he
purchased two acres of Lytle Ranch Land
back in the 80s it was a good price he
said and not too far from Las Vegas
and Like the 6 000 other people living
in the Moapa Valley its ruralness is a
huge draw but the muddy river that runs
through it oh my goodness is known to
flood and several of the surrounding
roads are just dirt the road going to my
house got destroyed and John Doe's
neighbor artudo viesca says the March
flood split the road up to his home in
half we need an emergency
like ambulance or somebody else
yeah we need the rose to be fixed to be
ready to any emergency
these roads may be dry now but people
like on trondo are fearing the next
flood and with no paved roads no street
lights not even addresses on the homes
they want the County's help but the
county says it's a give and take this is
not new Maryland Kirkpatrick is their
County Commissioner who says stronger
storms are posing more challenges we
don't have any structural Solutions so
we encourage the the residents to keep
the washes clean but to the regional
Flood Control District without necessary
infrastructure residents are responsible
for their own protection so how do they
get the infrastructure new homes and
businesses which would help pay for
other mitigations we've turned down many
of development but she says the
community rejects most expansion into
their rural lives not saying that they
have to grow but at the same time when
you live in a rural community there's
expectations of um what what you get for
services that expectation leaving
residents weighing the secluded life
with with enduring this again
we need this kind of help so we can move
on anjondo says